최근에 일론 머스크가 미국 상업용
부동산 그리고 이제 주택 가격이
폭락할 거라고 이야기를 했는데 미국
부동산 현재 시장이랑 미국 부동산이랑
한국 부동산이랑 다른 점이 뭔지 오늘
좀 알려 드리도록 하겠습니다 일론이
상업용 부동산이 붕괴될 거라고
했습니다 진짜 고금리가 오랫동안
이어지면서 거기서 장사하시는 분들이
좀 많이 어려워졌어요 그래서 실제로
저희가 인터뷰를 했을 때도 정말 지금
상황이 좋지 않다라는 이야기를 좀
많이 들었었습니다 그것뿐만 아니라
고금리가 계속 오랫동안 유지가 됐어요
우리나라 같은 경우에는 사실 그
미국과 비교해서는 금리가 그렇게 높은
편은 아니거든요 그래서 거기는 지금
담보대출 금리가 거의 뭐 최근에 조금
내리긴 했지만 뭐 5 6% 기본이고
뭐 7% 대도 있고 진짜 높은 금리로
되게 오랫동안 이어졌어요 그래서
그걸로 인해서 진짜 문제가 발생된
그런 부동산들이 많이 생겨나기 시작을
했고 정말 견디지 못해서 던지는 그런
부동산 매물들도 많이 생기기
시작했습니다 미국이 특히 좀 재택
근무가 너무 활성화되다 보니까 오피스
공실률이 제가 알고 있기로는 세
1이에요 개인주의가 워낙 심하고
출근은 안 하는 경우가 많기 때문에
보통은 이제 오피스 수요 때문에
인근에 이제 이런 장사하시는 분들이
잘 되는 거거든요 오피스에 출근하는
사람이 없다 보니까 그 인근에 있는
상권은 다 죽었어요 그래서 실제로
제가 최근에 뉴욕 갔을 때도 정말
오피스 공신력뿐만 아니라 거기 인근에
이런 상가들이 좀 많이 비어
있었습니다네 그러다 보니까 우리가 막
뉴스에서 지금 보는 막 미국 부동산이
반토막 됐다 뭐 10분가 가격으로
됐다 이런게 뭐냐면 미국은 임대 수익
기준으로 가치를 산정을 해요 근데
그거와 반에 한국은 담보 가치
기준으로 가치를 산정을 합니다 그리고
거기 플러스 그 대출받는 사람 신용
기준으로 이제 대출을 해 줘요 그래서
만약에 공실률이 되게 심해지면 미국
같은 경우에는 진짜 반토막이 나거나
1분 가격이 되거나 진짜 헐값이
되거나 이런게 말이 되는 거예요네
근데 우리나라 같은 경우에는
기본적으로 담보가치 이제 주변에
매각된 사례 기준으로 치를 산정해서
막 미국처럼 반토막이 나거나 뭐 진짜
1분 가격이 되거나 이런게 없습니다
그래서 그 부분을 좀 기억하셨으면
좋겠고 그리고 지금 한국부동산 같은
경우에도 자영업자분들이 매우 힘든
상황이에요 작년 같은 경우에 거의
약한 100만 명 정도가 폐업할
정도로 지금 자영업자분들 상황이 좋지
않습니다 그래서 우리나라도 어찌 됐든
고금리가 오랫동안 이루어졌고 그다음에
물가도 많이 올랐고 인건비도 많이
올라서 자영업자분들이 지금 일하기가
너무 힘든 상황이에요 그리고 무엇보다
소매업이 폐업률이 제일 높습니다
그래서 여러분들이 나중에 빌딩
투자하시고 상업용
투자하신다기에
공실률이 되게 높아질 수 있어요
그러다 보니까 지금 한국 부동산
리테일 같은 경우에도 진짜 작년 같은
경우에 폐업률이 100만 명이 넘을
정도로 되게 좀 심각한 상황이라고
보시면 될 거 같고 그리고 오피스
같은 경우에도 미국 정도는 아니에요
우리나라는 상대적으로 그렇게 높진
않습니다 우리나라는 아직까지 이렇게
모여서 같이 식사도 하고 같이 얘기도
도 하고 회의도 하고 이런게
아직까지는 좀 있다 보니까 미국보다는
오피스 공실율이 그렇게 심하진 않지만
근데 이제 이면에 있는 이런 꼬마
빌딩 작은 규모의 빌딩들은 그래도
오피스 공실률이 되게 높은 편이에요
지금 오피스 되는 건물들 보면은 다
이제 프라임급 빌딩 진짜 테 난로에
있는 빌딩 여의도 메인에 있는 빌딩
이런 빌딩들은 좀 되고 나머지 거기
이면에 있는 작은 빌딩 같은 경우에는
공실률이 되게 높은 편입니다 그리고
지금 스타트업들이 신규 투자 유치가
되게 어려워요 그래서 작년 같은
경우에는 신규 투자 건수가 약 한 3
40% 더 줄었습니다 그리고 지금
신규 투자 유치가 제일 좋았던
20년도 21년다는 월등이 나지 거의
반토막 날 정도로 신규 투자 건수가
매우 줄었습니다네 그러다 보니까
사무실을 확장 이전하거나 규모를
늘리는 경우가 좀 많이 없다 보니까
오피스 공실률이 되게 높아진 부분도
있습니다 공실률을 좀 보자면
우리나라에서 공실률이 지금 제일
심각한 데가 가로 스킬이에요 그래서
지금 뭐 그때 데이터로 봤을 때는
36 . 5%라고 하지만 실제로 가서
보면 거의 반이 다비어 있어요 그리고
이제 명동 같은 경우에도 원래
공실률이 50% 아지 늘어났다가
최근에 10% 이내로 좀
줄어들었습니다 외국인 관광객들이
오면서 그리고 지금 공실률이 제일
낮은 곳은 지금 성수동이네 성수동은
진짜 뭐 한 88% 7% 정도 될
정도로 성수동 공실률은 되게 낮은
편입니다 트렌드에 따라서 공실률
차이가 되게 큰 거 같아요 그리고
저는 무엇보다 데이터 중에 그 고령화
데이터를 제가 항상 보거든요 지금 2
2024년 기준으로 65세 이상
인구가 19% 그니까 약 20%
그래서 보통 이제 세계적으로 65세
인구가 20% 정도가 되면 초고령화
사회라고 합니다 그래서 우리나라는
어떻게 보면 지금 초고령화 사회로
접어들었어요 지금을 기준으로 10년
뒤로 보면은 이게 30% 늘어납니다
그럼 진짜 저희가 길 걸어다니다가
한네 명 중에 한 명은 다 65세
이상 인구에 그래서 그거를 보면은
우리가 어렸을 때 갔던 그런 상권들
다 다 어떻게 변할지 모릅니다 진짜
심각하게 안 좋아질 수도 있어요
우리나라 특성상 이제 시대 흐름이
어떻게 가는지를 여러분들이 파악을
하셔야지 나중에 이런 상권 변화라든지
이런게 어떻게 흘러가는지 파악할 수
있습니다 언론에서도 많이 나오지만
대학교 신규 인원들도 계속 줄어들고
있고 그리고 여대도 지금 인원이 많이
부족해서 지금 남자 학생들도 받겠다고
막 하고 난리잖아요 지금 젊은
사람들이 좀 많이 없습니다 그래서 그
정도로 되게 우리나라가 초고령화
사회가 되고 있다 그리고 제가 또
데이터 준비한 거 중에 서울 아파트
가격별로 이제 그 상승률 데이터를 좀
가져왔는데 보시면은 가격이 비싼
아파트 상승률이 더 높아요네 그래서
여러분들이 이거를 되게 유심하게
보셔야 되는게 가격이 싼 거는 많이
안 올라요 근데 가격이 좋고 사람들이
좋아할 만한 그런 아파트는 가격
상승률이 더 높았습니다 왜냐면
사람들이 다 그걸 사고 싶어하고 이런
새로생긴 부자들이 그런 걸도 많이
사거든요 비싸게 예 그러면서 격차가
좀 많이 늘어나요 그래서 여러분들이이
지금 서울 아파트 가격 상승률 표도
한번 좀 유심히 보셨으면 좋겠어요
빌딩도 비슷해요 요거를 좀 참고하셔서
이제 누구나 다 좋아할 만한 공급은
제한되어 있고 우리나라 사람들이 다
알 만한 어 그런 부동산에 투자하는게
상승률이 더 크다 어 이렇게 보시면
될 거 같고 그리고 또 하나 데이터는
부자 데이터 부자 데이터 한국의
부자가 얼마나 많은지 작년에 사실
자영업자나 이렇게 힘드신 분들 너무
많긴 했지만 부자의 수는 더 많이
늘어났습니다 지금 올해도 아마 더
늘어날 거고 내년에는 아마 진짜
폭발적으로 늘어날 거 같아요 그래서
내년에는 아마 코인 부자나 미국
주식으로 투자하던 분들 새로운
부자들이 아마 폭발적으로 늘어날
겁니다 미국 주식 가격이 많이 오르긴
했지만 안 파신 분들이 많거든요
내년이나 아니면 내 후년에 이분들이
돈을 어느 정도 벌면 일부를
부동산으로 좀 바꿔 놓으려고 할
거예요 그리고 지금 최근에 신현대
이제 재건축 된다라고 아마 기사
보셨을 텐데 63 벨딩 정도 높이
그니까 그 이상으로 어 재건축을
한다라고 합니다 근데 만약에 이제 그
정도로 지어지면 정말 몇백억 정도
하는 그런 아파트들이 되게 많아질 것
같아요 그리고 이제 그런 코인 투자자
분들이나 미국 주식 투자하던 분들이
최고가를 계속 경신할 겁니다 아마
이런 양극화는 더 심해질 것 같다
지금 같은 시기에는 더 그럴 거
같아요 그니까 지금 한국의 경제
성장률을 뭐 최근에 또 금리 내리긴
했지만 진짜 2% 대였다 지금 막
1% 대까지 얘기 나오고 있잖아요
그래서 진짜 좀 저성장으로 제가 봤을
때 되게 오래 갈 거 같긴 하거든요
지금 같은 시기에는 부동산 사실 거면
정말 확실한 위치에 누구나 다 살
만한 그리고 나중에 시장에 내놨을 때
그런 뭐 코인 투자자분들이 뭐 미국
주식 투자하셔도 분들이 되게
매력적으로 가질 만한 어 그런
부동산에 투자하는게 저는 가장
안정적이라고 생각을 합니다 뭐 오늘
제가 뭐 미국 부동산부터 한국 부동산
지금 시장사 그리고 자영업자 뭐
공실률 막 이런 걸 쭉 설명드렸는데이
부분을 계속 유심히 보실 필요가
있어요 도대체 지금 어떤 상황이고
다른 나라는 어떤 상황이고 지금
공실률이 어떻고 자영업자가 어떻고
그리고 최근에 뭐 부자들 수가 어느
정도 됐고 그런 거를 종합적으로
파악해야지 여러분들이 부동산 투자하실
때 좀 판단을 하실 수 있다라고
생각을 하거든요 사실 지금 우리나라
경제가 매우 안 좋은 상황이에요 근데
안 좋은 상황인데 불과하고 돈 많은
사람들은 계속 많아지고 있고 체고가
경신하는 건 계속 경신되고 있습니다
여러분들이 아마 판단하시기 쉽지 않을
거 같은데 지금 같은 시기가 되게
신중해 신중해 신중을 해야 되는
부분이 있어요 반드시 제가 말씀
드렸던 그런 부분들을 종합적으로
판단을 한 다음에 진짜 누구나 다
사고 싶어 하는 어 그런 부동산에
투자 해야지 이런 투자 실패를 줄일
수 있다라고 저는 생각을 합니다
그래서 오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요
다음 시간에 뵙겠습니다
[음악]
감사합니다 a